no cold open gag on this one cause um
i couldn't think of anything i was
comfortable with
[Music]
generally on this channel when i talk
about representation the focus is on
lgbtqia plus representation because
well that's my wheelhouse and it's the
specific area i feel most comfortable
talking about for what should be fairly
obvious reasons
i rarely step out of that to talk about
other forms of representation at least
not in any massive depth because
well i don't want to speak for a
community i don't belong to and as a
result of that accidentally cause more
harm than good
nevertheless i'm going to make an
attempt here and hopefully
not massively embarrass myself in the
process
so
today we are going to be talking about
issues with common representations of
people with disabilities and there's a
few things to make clear right off the
bat i myself
do not have a physical disability and
while i have a number of very dear
friends who do shout out to my friend
meg for consulting on this video
i need it to be known that for that
reason
my voice
should not be taken as any kind of
authority on this issue
i am neurodivergent thank you adhd but
when it comes to the tropes around the
depictions of neurodivergence or mental
illness which aren't the same thing to
be clear on that
that's
kind of a whole other bundle of issues
that it would have to be a completely
separate conversation altogether if i
even feel like doing it so the focus
here will be on the depictions of
physical disabilities in various forms
from those a character has had since
birth to those acquired during life
those clearly visible those invisible to
the naked eye and even narrowing it down
to physical disability we have got
a lot of ground to cover and the last
thing i want to say before we get
started
is as is often the case
i'm going to be focusing on the problems
with the patterns and tropes in these
depictions that does not mean that there
are no instances where some of the
things that i will be talking about
actually worked or were done
respectfully
it's just that the most common
depictions carry certain connotations
either inherently or that they very
easily slip into
and i promise i'll try to avoid putting
caveats on every single statement i make
in this video i'm just i'm just trying
to cover my bases as best as i possibly
can as early as i can so without all
said
let's get going
oh geez i'm really gonna start okay
all right i suppose i have to define
your terms and all that what is physical
disability well
webster's dictionary defines physical
disability as
why are you stealing this gag from
abigail thorne you lazy hack
fascinating
okay in all seriousness bringing it down
to its most basic a physical disability
is any condition that inhibits what are
generally considered to be basic
physical activities now this can include
but is not limited to
walking lifting speaking hearing and
seeing and
well actually pretty much anything
somebody like me takes completely for
granted now the nature of the various
conditions that cause this will vary
wildly some are conditions people are
born with such as various forms of palsy
or underdeveloped limbs or many hearing
impairments some are caused by events
later in life such as physical trauma
which may necessitate amputation of a
limb the contraction of a disease that
leaves long-term or permanent physical
damage or inherited conditions that may
worsen with time or not even present
symptoms until later in life
these conditions may result in the need
of assisting devices things like canes
walkers or motorized chairs for mobility
and then there's hearing aids prosthetic
limbs so on but the point here is that
physical disability is not just one
thing it's not even a single grouping of
things it is many things that takes many
forms but
at the core of it a physical disability
makes navigating through day-to-day life
difficult
because by and large the world is built
by and for people who don't have these
kinds of limitations
that having been established
let's get going properly
so the first thing i want to bring up is
that if a disabled character is the lead
of a story it's almost guaranteed that
that story will be
pretty much about their disability
this is not dissimilar to how trans
narratives are framed making the
transition the centerpiece of the story
and implicitly of the character's entire
life so if you remember the video i did
on that topic before then that might
help you understand where i'm getting at
here and kind of get you a little bit
ahead of things
with disability specifically this is
where you'll find films such as mask my
left foot
wonder the theory of everything and the
diving bell and the butterfly
however if you're familiar with these
movies or others in a similar vein
you may have noticed that it's pretty
common for the disabled character to
share top billing
with their caregiver now that's not
automatically some kind of negative
caregivers are an important aspect of
life for many disabled people and
caregivers are certainly deserving of
recognition and appreciation
though it should be pointed out not all
disabled people have or require
caregivers there are many conditions
that while they affect day-to-day life
they don't require regular assistance
from another person however in these
stories where a disabled person is the
lead or the co-lead a caregiver is
almost always present
now as i said with most tropes
and patterns it isn't always bad when
looked at in an individual story but
when you look at the fact that this is a
prevalent framing
then it requires some closer examination
having a caregiver character especially
one with essentially equal billing in
terms of screen time and narrative
importance
provides an outside perspective on
events which
that's fine in and of itself except it's
not uncommon for audiences to be given
as much reason to empathize with the
caregiver as the disabled character
often even to empathize with the
caregiver more if only for being more
relatable to a non-disabled audience
now
that's possibly a bit of an
oversimplification on my part but when
virtually every story focusing on a lead
character with a disability gives equal
time to the struggles of non-disabled
people
well it means that disabled characters
don't really have stories just about
them it's also about how hard it is to
care for love and otherwise be around
them and that's
that's not a great note for these
stories to keep hitting over and over
again
but broadly speaking in the more
grounded drama type versions of these
stories you tend to end up with one of
two things the first is a story where
the disabled character basically
has no character arc regardless of
whether or not they are the nominal lead
because character development is instead
focused on the people around them
needing to be more understanding
accepting etc
as for stories where the disabled
character does have an arc
that is where we tend to get
now this one
boy there's a lot to unpack okay
on the surface this should be good
direct focus on the disabled character
including actually granting them an arc
and character development and
celebrating how they thrive in the face
of adversity what's not to love
well again the issue is more on the
prevalence of this narrative than in any
individual instance but there's a number
of pretty sizable issues
with this one
especially with the fact that it is
among the most common stories that gets
told with the disabled lead character
firstly
not all disabled people view their
conditions as something that actually
needs to be overcome for many they don't
view the problem as being something
inherent in them and what difficulties
they face are about a lack of
accommodation which really is a societal
problem
so
triumph over adversity stories already
have a framing that presents being
disabled as more of a problem for the
individual
which it's on them to overcome
so taking that into consideration there
is a frequent undercurrent most likely
unintentional but it runs through these
kinds of stories and to be brutally
blunt about it it basically amounts to
isn't it great how this person is able
to thrive without society having to
fundamentally shift to accommodate them
which then in turn carries a subtle
implication that
disabled people having difficulty in
their lives just haven't worked hard
enough
they
need to overcome the problem
their problem
again i can't think of an instance where
this implication came across as the
actual intended message but as often
happens with any kind of minority
representation especially when being
written and created and overseen by
people who are not part of that minority
the full implications aren't properly
examined by the creators who
when these problems get pointed out to
them they tend to end up floundering
well we didn't mean it that way
and i'm sure they didn't
but lack of intent doesn't remove the
implications and the undercurrents just
like how treasure hunting stories almost
always carry an undercurrent of
colonialism regardless of intent it's
just kind of there unless you do a lot
of work to combat it like how national
treasure being set in the u.s and being
about finding a treasure placed by the
founding fathers so the treasure itself
is functionally no older than the
country
that does
a fair bit to soften the usual issue of
white guy goes to ancestral area of a
foreign country and raids it for shiny
things
so there are just inherent implications
and issues with a story that celebrates
a disabled person's ability to function
in society as it currently stands in a
way
despite appearing to celebrate disabled
characters it actually reinforces the
status quo of a world built for people
without notable disabilities and treats
as triumphant the mere act of being able
to exist in a space that was never built
for you
and there's another
problem with the prevalence of these
triumph over adversity stories
not all disabilities can be overcome
there are loads of conditions that are
not only incurable but degenerative they
will only ever get worse with time so
even if someone in that situation can
function in a world not designed for
their disability right now it's not
going to stay that way because their
condition will worsen for many disabled
people overcoming their condition is
simply not possible no matter how hard
they try or anyone around them tries and
on the rare occasions when mainstream
entertainment deals with conditions like
these for their lead characters that's
where we get an alternate framing
instead of the triumph of the story
being over the disability itself there's
something else so
extraordinary about them
that it causes society to do that
incredibly rare thing and actually make
the effort to accommodate them so this
is where you get your real life stories
like my left foot about writer and
painter christy brown or the theory of
everything about physicist stephen
hawking
in both cases the conditions they had
cerebral palsy and slow progression als
respectively were not things over which
a person could triumph or overcome
instead these stories focused on their
accomplishments laudable in of
themselves and made more notable for
their disabilities and that's
fine but the underlying message isn't
really all that much better than the
traditional triumph over adversity one
before we had c you could succeed in
this world not built for you if you put
in a little more effort and now we have
well you know
maybe if you wrote a book that became an
academy award-winning film or invented
string theory we'd put a little more
effort into accommodating you too
as you can see
it's height adjustable and we can change
the angle to whatever steve wants it at
you know it's cutting edge
again i'm being harsh in the way i'm
putting this and i'm well aware of that
but it's because i'm trying to be as
clear as i can about all of this
now the triumph over adversity or
exceptional disabled person narratives
often come paired
with another recurring issue
[Music]
this usually comes up with disabilities
that occur or get worse later in life as
with the aforementioned theory of
everything now keep in mind that when i
say tragic framing i'm talking about the
framing of the disability itself not of
the entire story being told it's not
that these stories lack happy or
triumphant endings as noted many
triumphant stories do have this rather
is that the disability itself is framed
as negatively as possible
now for people without disabilities this
might seem like an odd thing to
criticize because
how can a disability not be a bad things
it removes the chance for a
normal
life now i put the word normal in
quotations
and that's because it's a deeply
arbitrary designation and the standard
for what is or isn't normal is
constructed in a way that frequently
excludes minority groups of all kinds in
one way or another and i've actually
been avoiding the term quotation marks
or no
but i wanted to touch on it here because
while we could debate all day long over
what is or isn't
normal or whether the term even has any
true meaningful use in the first place
the concept of it
is often at the hearts of these stories
and these framings treating what the
expected audience views as normal being
good and treating anything which
disrupts that as bad underlying all of
this is the base assumption that anyone
not
normal
must want to be
i'm going to be avoiding the word from
here on out but i needed to address that
undercurrent and confront it directly
before we got any further
so another aspect of tragic framing is
often
upping the degree of hardship that
results from a disability a nice go-to
example of that is freddy freeman from
the film shazam there are scenes that go
out of their way to show that freddy is
frequently bullied for his condition and
i would never say that disabled people
aren't bullied because yeah they
frequently are but the thing i wanted to
note here
is that despite his use of a crutch
making it clear that he has a disability
we never actually find out what it is
not in the film itself there are
a number of possibilities but nothing's
confirmed within the text
this does two things
the first is that if the character's
actual condition is kept vague then the
film is not under any obligation to be
accurate to the details of a real-life
condition
and the other thing
is that when this is paired with the
aforementioned bullying
it means that from a storytelling
perspective
this appears to be a means to an end
the end
being victimhood
time is being spent on bullying but not
at specifying what disability freddie is
actually living with
as if it matters more that he be painted
as tragic and a victim than it is for
him to represent an actual disability
which real people deal with
an inclination towards tragic framing
may be rooted in the perspectives of
people without disabilities viewing them
from the outside i mean honestly it's a
bit like a straight guy saying
i don't get what's so appealing about
kissing another man
of course you don't
because you're not gay so along those
same lines the perception of i don't see
how anyone with a disability could see
it as anything other than tragic
well of course he can't
because it's not your life or your
experience that's not to imply that
there aren't some disabled people who
feel a sense of tragedy about this
situation but these framings seem to
assume that
all disabled people view themselves that
way or it just disregards their view of
themselves altogether in order to frame
them that way now for context and to be
fair this is most often seen in stories
of acquired disabilities as opposed to
ones characters have had from birth and
in that context it's not entirely unfair
to presume that someone who previously
lived without disabilities is going to
have at best a period of adjustment and
well possibly even a period of mourning
for the life they no longer have once
they have to start living with a
disability but at the same time
realistic or not
including these moments these feelings
this framing
isn't a requirement of depicting a
disabled character including these
things is a choice that creators are
making and they keep making it over and
over centering tragedy and pain as the
core of the disabled experience and if
you're going to put a spotlight on the
difficulty of adjusting to having a
disability
well that is where we get
if the story in which a disabled
character appears isn't primarily about
their living with a disability i.e
they're not the lead then it's pretty
common for a disability to become a
motivator for character action
that
as with much of this is fine in and of
itself
but the prevalence of this
means that it's actually exceedingly
rare for a character to simply have a
disability as a character trait
instead the disability and very commonly
the desire to reverse it will drive
specific character choices as if the
writers felt that there had to be a plot
reason for a character to have a
disability now
admittedly this is a tricky thing to
balance because
if you write a story where a character's
disability
never really factors into anything and
the character is treated just like
everybody else but also happens to make
use of a wheelchair
well then you run the risk of token
representation where the distinguishing
trait could have been swapped out for
anything else without actually requiring
any meaningful changes to the story or
the characters involved
but the thing about disability like any
character trait or attribute it doesn't
need to have a logistical impact on the
story in order to avoid being seen as
token it can simply be something that
informs the characterization and the way
the character behaves talks and is
perceived
but most of the time it instead is used
to push characters into making specific
decisions turning disability into more
of a plot mechanic than a character
trait
it doesn't help that these are almost
always bad or self-serving decisions
that they're making i think some
specific examples would help be
illustrative of this so there's the
classic spider-man villain the lizard if
you don't know him he's basically a
werewolf but he turns into a hulking
reptile instead of a big huggable bundle
of fur and teeth
his origin stems from the fairly classic
scientist experiments on self-stalk
monster origin but the reason he's
experimenting and the reason his science
juice is specifically lizard flavored is
because he lost his arm and is hoping to
harness the reptilian ability to regrow
limbs and well he does do that but it
comes with the whole vicious beast thing
so that's not a trade most would have
gone for so his disability not only
drove him to self-experiment but
specifically informed of the nature of
that experimentation and thus the nature
of his monstrosity then there's
professor charles xavier in this case
i'm going to be specifically referring
to his depiction in the film days of
future past because at that point in
that story charles has suffered the
injury that cost him the use of his legs
but thanks to a serum created by hank
mccoy aka beast he is able to walk
but the serum comes at a price because
it dampens charles's mutant powers and
without his telepathic abilities
everything in the story becomes more
difficult to accomplish
so we have complication by way of
attempting to negate a disability and
i'll also point out that both the
filming and the conversation around the
serum gives it pretty direct parallels
to drugs like heroin
and also
it's the exact same serum that mccoy is
using to suppress his own very visible
mutation so the same thing that
literally keeps a man from looking like
a monster also removes a disability
ain't that a lovely association
let's step off of comic book characters
for a second and talk about victor from
the recent show arcane
since this show is still relatively new
if you haven't seen it and you plan to
you can skip to the following time code
to avoid being spoiled
victor has an unspecified degenerative
condition which limits his mobility and
will eventually kill him victor is for a
decent stretch of the story frequently
serving as the voice of reason and
morals to his science bro jace
reminding jace that their original goal
for their inventions was to help the
people with the harshest living
conditions not just benefit those who
are already on top
but then when victor's condition starts
to get worse he betrays those principles
and tries to use the research they do to
reverse his own condition inadvertently
killing a friend in the process
so his disability and the fear of it
worsening drives the character's bad
decisions
this kind of thing happens a lot you'll
notice it's pretty consistently framed
in the negative
about the best one can hope for is
something along the lines of doctor
strange
steven strange was a renowned surgeon
but then he had an accident which ruined
the stability in his hands he sought out
the mystical arts in the hope of finding
a cure where traditional medicine was
failing now this ultimately does turn
him into a hero dr strange otherwise
known as the sorcerer supreme
so unlike the other side example so far
the end result itself is not a bad thing
however
he's still driven by a desire to reverse
his condition
with loss of status amongst his peers
being a major factor in all that more so
than the idea that he could save more
lives if his hands worked some things
just can't be fixed life without my work
is still life this isn't the end there
are other things that can give your life
meaning like why you
so as a glory chaser we've already got a
pretty selfishly tinged motive
that also brings in that tragic framing
we talked about before
actually since we've started getting
into superheroes here i think i'd like
to talk about some of the oddities of
disability representation in
some of my favorite genres
now the first thing i want to touch on
is one of those things that didn't
really apply to the earlier sections
because
anything that's set in the real world is
going to reflect real world disability
accommodations i.e
next to none but something that's very
easy for non-disabled creators to
overlook when creating original worlds
like in science fiction or fantasy is
recognizing that the presence or absence
of disability accommodation
says something about the world that
you've created i ran into this one
personally with my novel dreams of fire
i'm not just doing this to plug the book
though there is a link below to buy it
my editor pointed out that i had
references to stairs but none to ramps
which implied that the world i created
didn't accommodate people with movement
disabilities now there's nothing
automatically wrong or bad with creating
a world like that but i think it's
helpful to realize that's what you're
doing and i hadn't realized that because
once it was pointed out i knew i had to
address it because the way i wanted to
present the world of my story and what
problems i did want to exist there i
didn't want it to be a world in which
those with movement disabilities were
left to fend for themselves
but
when we're talking about science fiction
or fantasy which are the two major
genres in which the writer will have the
freedom to create a holy original world
that does not need to reflect the real
one
there are some pretty big allowances
that exist
which
don't exist in more realistic fiction
and that is perfect or near perfect
disability aids
as mentioned earlier there are devices
or other means of assisting a disabled
person in order to help them navigate a
world not built with their disability in
mind wheelchairs prosthetic limbs
hearing aids etc we've cited some of
these already well what's pretty common
in fantastical settings is to have an
accommodation for a disability be
magical based on technology far beyond
what exists in the real world or
otherwise fantastical think jordy
leforge's pfizer in star trek the next
generation or how blind superhero
daredevil his other senses are so
heightened that it compensates for his
sight in nearly all situations now on
the one hand this could be seen as
taking advantage of a unique aspect of
the genres of storytelling since such
perfect solutions aren't available in
more realistic fiction
however there is still a bit of a
problem with these kinds of depictions
when you have a means to counteract or
account for a disability that is so
effective the disability might as well
not even exist
do you actually still have a disabled
character
that's not to say that these situations
never have the disability come up
but it basically only happens when it
can impact the plot and very easily
loses the sense of being something the
character is actually dealing with day
to day it's
more like removing the disability aid is
a weakness to be exploited as the plot
or the villains see fit and functionally
that's no different from superman's
kryptonite allergy i mean
how many of us
actually think of bucky barnes the
winter soldier of marvel comics and the
mcu as being disabled
the man's missing an arm but he has an
absolutely perfect metal arm that
functions more as a super power than as
any kind of liability it's part of why
this moment
was pretty shocking
because it's very easy as he's depicted
in these films and shows for bucky's
missing arm to be forgotten about as
being a disability since the prosthetic
works perfectly 99.9 of the time oh i'll
get that up
now again this isn't all automatically
bad much like with not having
accommodations like ramps how that says
something about the world you've built
so too does having the kind of
technology or assistance that basically
removes the disability altogether in
this case it says that this world
doesn't just leave those with
disabilities to fend for themselves and
accommodates them far better than we do
however
it's addressing a problem by
fixing a disabled person so that they
can function in a world not built for
them rather than altering the greater
world so that their condition isn't that
disruptive to their lives in the first
place
just something to keep in mind
but we are going to move on because i
kind of touched on something there that
i want to dive further into
[Applause]
now this is different from disability as
character motivation because it's less
about forcing the decisions of the
specific disabled character and more
about shifting the plot as a whole so
remember two paragraphs ago when i said
for all intents and purposes bucky
doesn't really have a disability until
the writers decide to do something with
it well
this has a more common form found in all
genres of entertainment not just sci-fi
and fantasy now what we're about to talk
about is most commonly associated with
invisible disability so to quickly touch
on that an invisible disability is one
where you wouldn't know that a person
has a disability just by looking at them
because a lot of what we've talked about
so far you can basically spot with the
naked eye either by evidence of the
disability itself or by the visibility
of an assisting device
invisible disabilities often come in the
form of chronic conditions like diabetes
lupus fibromyalgia
ibs even food allergies
things that impact the people with these
conditions but other people wouldn't
know about unless they were told
these kinds of conditions partly due to
their invisible nature are prime
candidates for what i've come to think
of as plot convenient titus
this is a condition that is never
addressed except for when it can be used
to either force plot progression or be a
sudden complication to enhance drama
it's almost never just a background
element that the character is dealing
with it's almost always either totally
under control or a life-threateningly
urgent issue
the character who caused me to
start thinking about and using this term
was kasima from orphan black
now while it's certainly not without
merit and was a hell of an acting
showcase for its lead i've got
a lot of problems uh with orphan black
and we don't have time to get into all
of them but talking specifically about
kasima she suffers from an unspecified
condition that basically means she
coughs up blood when it's dramatically
appropriate
and can then force the other characters
to change whatever course they're on in
order to help her
but she's fine the rest of the time
whenever the plot doesn't need that
now i don't want to be overly dismissive
here
i'm not saying that the mere fact that
the condition flares up and comes down
is itself the issue there are plenty of
real world conditions that do the exact
same thing though as with freddie
freeman that i mentioned earlier the
creators opted for the safety of not
naming a real world condition
but ultimately
what i again a non-disabled person so
take what i'm about to say with a grain
of salt what i found irritating was that
the entire thing felt more like a means
to jolt the story whenever it stalled
rather than an actual aspect of her
character there is a fairly fine line
between depicting the difficulties of a
chronic condition
and using that condition as an on-call
plot defibrillator and it's a line i
personally feel or from black crossed
plot convenient titus can do everything
from remove a character who no longer
serves a plot function to simply being a
complication that ups the dramatic
stakes of the climax to serving as a
moment of triumph should the character
ever overcome it basically a mini
version of triumph over adversity
without making it the whole thing
but the point is
it's there to serve those plot functions
more than any amount of representation
or characterization that's why despite
my earlier examples of specific
invisible disabilities it's pretty
common for these to be unspecified as
was the case with kasima it doesn't
matter what the disability is
if it's just a plot device in the end
but there's
okay there's kind of a big aspect to all
this and
okay frankly i've been putting it off
until now
[Laughter]
now the reason i've been putting this
off is because it's possibly the most
loaded part of an already loaded topic
but yes there is a
long-running issue of disabilities
especially visible ones and especially
especially disfiguring ones being given
to villainous characters and this one
goes
way back from modern instances like
shadow weavers severe facial scarring
and shira and the princess of power to
dr knows prosthetic hands from the first
james bond movie to long john silver's
missing leg and treasure island to the
titular character's physical deformities
in shakespeare's richard iii
from twisted monstrosities and
adult-aimed horror films like mason
verger from hannibal to children's fair
like captain hook from peter pan or
howard clifford and detective pikachu
it's a fairly standard and
straightforward thing
to make a character instill a sense of
dread or unease in the audience
twist the human form into something
recognizable but not immediately
familiar
it's actually not that far off from a
deliberate evocation of the uncanny
valley effect where people get unsettled
when they know what they're looking at
is a person but something's off
something's not
what they expect
and
on paper
that should be fine the problem however
is that this reshaping of the human form
frequently perfectly mirrors real world
physical conditions actually i'd say it
does that about 99.9 of the time and the
thing is even positive characters with
disfiguring disabilities are often
introduced with the expectation that the
hero or at least the audience is wary
and put off by them just so that
expectation can be subverted a little
bit later this is basically the entire
gag behind scenes like the snuggly
duckling pub entangled but despite my
evil look and my temper and my heart
i've always yearned to be a concert
pianist
the joke only works on the base
assumption that the guy with the hook
for a hand is going to be perceived as a
threat by the audience until he suddenly
flips that on its head which has the
classic problem of such humor
in that yes it is subverting the trope
but only after evoking it as hard as
possible
and here's where we're going to circle
back around to what we brought up before
about disability driving character
motivation because
this is not only frequently the case
with disabled villains but in a
frightening amount of cases the
disability can actually be said to be
the cause of their villainy
a few quick examples
i mentioned howard clifford earlier
whose desperate attempts to find a cure
for his worsening physical condition
again never specifically naming it at
any point leads him down a path of
enslavement and forced body augmentation
and attempted murder john lumick from
series two of modern doctor who created
a version of the cybermen with the
ultimate goal of preserving his own mind
before his unspecified illness claims
his life now with characters like lumic
and clifford one might make the argument
that it's more a fear of death that's
driving these characters than their
disabilities
and there's some truth to that
but the storytellers are still choosing
to embody that fear of death in a
disabled person and one could equally
argue that their conditions made them
far more aware of their mortality and
thus push them further into villainy
than might have otherwise happened had
their disabilities not made them more
aware of it at the very least you have
to grant that their disabilities are
exacerbating the fears that are driving
their villainous actions
there isn't always an extrapolated fear
of dying though we already talked about
kirk connors aka the lizard and his
missing arm
missing arms seem to be a bit of a go-to
actually captain hook claw from black
panther then there's the albino orc from
the hobbit movies
actually albinism is also a go-to the
condition being seen either in villains
or uh occasionally characters with
effectively magic powers like caliban
and logan or powder
actually
since i started dipping back into comic
book examples back there i'd be remiss
to not bring up batman's rogues gallery
now it's well documented that many of
the key figures from batman's villains
are suffering from severe psychological
issues hence why they keep ending up in
an asylum but physical disability or
disfigurement abounds regardless the
obvious example being two-face who's
physical and psychological issues are
pretty intrinsically linked but there's
also the penguin whose body is misshapen
in a number of ways that tend to vary
from depiction to depiction but is
nearly always present in some form from
the misshapen hands given to him in
batman returns to the persistent limp he
had in gotham the character of killer
croc tends to be more depicted as a flat
out monster these days but when he was
first introduced he was basically just a
big guy with a skin condition now i've
started to touch on disfiguring
conditions and disabilities and this
aspect bears a little bit of a highlight
because while heroic characters aren't
above the occasional scar it's generally
going to be
or something cool
a cut across the cheek a nick that gives
them that segmented eyebrow look that
the kids really like these days
generally a whole bunch of single scars
carefully placed to ensure minimal
effect on the character's appearance
i mean there's a reason that the tv
version of gerion from game of thrones
only suffered a single cut across the
bridge of the nose and the cheek as a
result of the battle of black water
while book tyrion has been missing about
half his nose since then
anything that seriously reshapes the
face can be counted on as being a trait
reserved for villains be it silco and
arcane dr poison from wonder woman
affiliates from 300 heck most of the
entire persian army in 300 and countless
james bond villains seriously the james
bond franchise for all its supposed
reinvention over the years has never
been able to stop
doing this
heroes almost never have these kind of
severe or prominent disfigurements and
the only two prominent examples that i
can think of deadpool and jonah hex fall
firmly into the category of anti-hero
not that there's anything wrong with
anti-heroes but it kind of feels like an
admission that this kind of physical
state would never be granted to a
paragon type hero or anything close to
that
the pattern is pretty clear
if audiences can see something that is
clearly
wrong
with the character's body then the odds
of them being anything other than a
villain
are slim to none
most of the time this is where i would
lay out some examples of times when
movies or shows got it right
i'm not gonna do that this time not
because there aren't any but rather
because of my own status
being outside the disabled community i
don't feel comfortable with my ability
to identify the good instances i've got
some things that i think are good
examples but i am too aware of my own
blind spots to trust that i won't
accidentally cite examples that actually
have problems i haven't even considered
and didn't even talk about
so yeah we're going to be skipping over
that part this time and it can serve as
a reminder of what i said at the
beginning that while i speak
with the best of intentions i am
speaking as an outsider and i may well
have missed something important in all
of this
mine is not a voice you should be
prioritizing over actual people with
disabilities
but
i did want to talk about these issues
all the same
as best i could
and hopefully i didn't screw it up too
badly
i'm sure folks will let me know in the
comments either way
but
that's where i'm going to leave off
so what are your thoughts on the
patterns i've discussed what you think
might be a more positive examples just
remember to be respectful not just of me
but of other commenters as well
and
put your thoughts down in the comments
and let's talk about it
if you want to support what this channel
does and the kind of content i create i
have a patreon that is how i pay my
bills this is my living
any assistance is greatly appreciated
but in addition to that down in the
description you will find links to well
my book which i mentioned earlier but
also other things that i do
other platforms i'm on be it twitch tick
tock twitter etc
but um
don't feel too much pressure though
at the end of the day
you are the council
i am just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
patreon shout outs thank you to turok
shane ross oliver b melinda walters
robin powell for nobulax the poodle
edelon tracy scrabbit dharma michael
doyle vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor robin moore
shayla gourley and bookworm
you can support me as well
hear me mispronounce your name
sure i got some of those wrong
[Music]
um
[Music]